what's the perfect day in the life of
magnus carlson when he's training
so like what's a good training regimen
in terms of
you know daily kind of training do you
have to put in across many
days months and years uh to just keep
yourself sharp in terms of chess
i would say when i'm at home i do very
very little
deliberate practice
i've never been that guy at all like
i've i could never force myself to
just sit down and work so deliberate
practice just to maybe you can educate
me for some
grand masters what would that look like
just doing puzzles kind of thing or yeah
doing puzzles and opening analysis that
would be the main things
studying games
just studying games yeah a little bit
but i feel like
that's something that i do
it's not deliberate it's
like reading our article or reading a
book
like i love chess books i'll read just
anything
and i'll find something interesting
so chess books that are like on openings
and stuff like that or just books that
go over different games yeah um both
books on
so there are three main categories there
are books on openings and there are
books on strategy and there are books on
chess history and i found all of them
very very interesting like what fraction
of the day would you say you have a
chess board
floating somewhere in your head
meaning like you're thinking about it
probably be a better question to ask how
many hours a day i don't have a
chessboard yeah
[Laughter]
i mean it could be just floating there
and nothing is happening but like i i
often do it parallel to some other
activity though and what what does that
look like like are you daydreaming like
different is it actual positions you're
just [ __ ] around with like fumbling
with different pieces in your head
often i've looked at a
at a random game on my phone for
instance or
in a book and then
my brain just keeps going at the same
position analyzing it and often it goes
all the way you know to the end game and
those are actual games or you conjure up
like fake games
no they were often based on real games
and then i'm i'm thinking like oh but it
wouldn't be more interesting if the
pieces were a little bit different and
then often i play it out from there
so you don't have uh
like you don't sit behind a computer or
a chess board and you lay out the pieces
and no
i'm not at all a poster board for
deliberate practice i could never
i could never work that way my first
coach
he gave me some
exercises to do at home
sometimes but he realized at some point
uh that wasn't gonna work yeah
because i wouldn't do it really or enjoy
it
so what
he would do instead is that at the
school where i had the trainings with
him there was
this
massive chess library so it's just like
yeah pick pick up books you can have
anything
you can have anything you want uh just
pick up books you like and then you give
back the next time so that's kind of
what i did instead yeah i just
absolutely raided
and then
my next tournament i will try out one of
the openings from that book if it was an
opening book and so on so does it feel
like a struggle like challenging like to
to be thinking those positions there's a
fun and relaxing no it's completely fine
i don't
like if it's a difficult position to
figure out you know like to calculate
when i go on to something else okay
like if i can't figure it out then
you know i'll go on
change it so that's easier to figure out
there was a point in your life where
cause probably was interested in being
your coach
or charlie's training with you why why
did you choose not to go with him that's
pretty bold move
was there a good reason for this no um
the first
like homework exercise he gave me was
to analyze like he picked out i think
three four of my worst losses and she
wanted me to to analyze them and give
him
my thoughts and it wasn't that there
were painful losses or anything that
that was a problem i just didn't really
enjoy
that
also i felt that
this whole structured approach and
everything yes i just felt like from the
start it was was a hassle so i loved the
idea of being able to pick his brain
but everything else i just
you know couldn't see myself
couldn't see myself enjoying and
at the end of the day i did then and
always have played
for fun that's always been like my main
reason so it's great that you had the
confidence to sort of
basically turn down the approach
of one of the greatest chess players of
all time at that time probably the
greatest chess player of all time i i
don't think i thought of it that way
i just thought this is not for me i'm
gonna try another way i don't think i
was particularly thinking that this is
my one opportunity or anything it was
just yeah i don't enjoy this let's try
something else
you